keeping the pumps working synopic is the
latest entrance to Sri Lanka's fuel
sector and it's wasting no time after
securing a license to import store
distribute and sell fuel
China's second largest oil and gas
producer is one of three companies
that's being allowed in by the
government
it will take over 150 fuel stations from
the existing Network and invest in
opening 50 more this competition should
be there then only then now you can see
that they are selling I think three
rupees less than the actual market price
the fuel sector was badly affected by
Sri Lanka's worst economic crisis in
2022 with the government not having
enough dollars to import supplies queues
stretched up to 10 kilometers in some
places and motorists were forced to wait
days to top up the state operator and
the only private operator the Indian Oil
Company struggled to cope with demand
new entrance in the market have to
Source their own funds from outside the
country
the government has a problem without
enough dollars now with cinepec and
these companies paying for petrol and
Diesel the government can use its
currency for the health sector and other
Essentials the customers can buy what
they need we can also order what we want
and there's a discount price as well
while some people were concerned about
privatization a vital State assets these
motorists are happy with companies
things will be more competitive this is
the system followed overseas this hasn't
been possible in Sri Lanka due to
politics and greed because if there's a
bribe to be made from everything this is
the way to get rid of that this is a
relatively small cut for Global
petrogiants but analysts say the
country's strategic positioning makes it
an important place to be and timing is
key the best historical opportunity
these Powers have to get their slice of
the pie in Sri Lanka because a Sri Lanka
that has risen a Sri Lanka that is
growing exponentially I mean it has the
power to maneuver it has the power to
negotiate but it's a drop bottom that's
when it has no power to negotiate that's
when other people other powers other
interests can input impute terms into
the negotiating process in addition to
the retail Market cynopek is hoping to
secure a four billion dollar project to
set up a refinery in southern Sri Lanka
where China operates a port
opening up the retail market cyanopac
and to our International firms will ease
the pressure on the government which has
had to spend a large chunk of its income
on importing fuel consumers are hoping
the competition will bring them some
benefits
Al Jazeera Colombo
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera